visit the historic west side near the
West Las Vegas Art Center you'll notice
a new public art on display through new
murals were unveiled today as part of a
larger effort to revitalize the
community the project was funded by the
mayor's fund for Las Vegas life each
mural has a special meaning behind it
including one with a special sign
language initiative the coordinator
behind the project Chase McCurdy hopes
the murals will inspire those who see
them
if we can capture attention and ignite
imaginations along with reinforcing
ideas of community and in different and
creative ways celebrating the community
and the culture of this area we love to
do such McCarty says they plan to add
more murals in the future that will
memorialize Community leaders and
celebrate what the west side is all
about
[Music]